hey you guys flickers of fear time once
again where i attempt to get through my
whole huge list of
unseen and unreviewed horror movies so
it's gonna take me like the rest of my
life but uh you know it's an enjoyable
journey so uh we're here for it so this
one that i want to talk about today i
kind of really wanted to highlight this
one uh because
i feel like this one doesn't get
mentioned a lot even though it's pretty
awesome
and i actually didn't even hear about it
when it first came out it came out back
in 2012
and it's called excision
now this is one of those movies uh and i
think i brought this up on this show
before that periodically i will kind of
go through you know i'll go to different
horror blogs and different sites and
i'll look at their lists of you know
best underseen movies you know on movies
you haven't heard about blah blah blah
from like the last 20 years or what have
you so i can kind of get an idea of the
[ __ ] that i'm missing out on
so this movie turned up on a couple
lists like that
so i wrote it down noted it and then
probably about i think i first watched
it like maybe two or three years ago
because i noticed that 2b had it for
free as far as i know it's still on
there for free so if you want to watch
it on there with a couple of ads you can
uh it's also on amazon prime if you're a
subscriber you can watch it for free as
well the weird thing about it is that
when i went to watch it because i said
well i guess i'll watch it on amazon
prime so i don't you know have to watch
the ads on 2b or whatever but amazon
prime
has two versions of it um one that's
like 1.99 or 299 to rent and then one
that's free with subscription but as far
as i can tell they're both the same so
don't feel it because for for at first i
kind of thought oh well maybe the one
you pay for has like is like director's
cut or has scenes that were cut out or
whatever but it's exactly the same
movie and it's exactly the same length
it's an hour and 21 minutes so like i
said if you have amazon prime then you
can watch it on there for free so as i
said this is one that kept coming up on
a lot of lists and it sounded like
pretty cool like it sounded like right
up my alley is it a horror movie yeah
but
it's kind of like more a really [ __ ]
up
black comedy sort of like it's funny but
it's also kind of like but it also has
elements of
tragedy i guess but that's like more
toward the end
during most of its run time it's just
this really kind of uncomfortably
funny twisted kind of
sort of gross
type of movie it's real it's kind of
hard to explain but it's actually i
loved this movie actually and i watched
it a second time like for this review
and i enjoyed it just as much this time
it's just it's so good and i just feel
like i don't i don't see a lot of people
talking about it and like i said like
with most horror movies it's not for
everybody uh this one's
pretty disgusting like it goes into it
especially there's if you're squik if
you're squicked out by like menstrual
type of stuff you might be grossed out
but it's like it's really really bloody
there's a lot of
organs like a lot of stuff about surgery
and stuff like that so you know if
that's i've seen this compared actually
to may which i talked about a couple
weeks back i've also seen it compared to
american mary so if you liked those two
movies and i can kind of see where
uh where that comparison is coming from
so if you like those two movies you
probably would dig this one as well
so the writer director of this uh was a
guy named richard bates jr and i guess
that he had made excision as a short
film back in 2008 and then as usually
happens like it gets a lot of you know
it kind of gets a lot of attention and
then they expand it to feature length so
2012 it premiered at sundance and seemed
like it got a little bit of buzz at
least at the time like i said it seems
like one that i don't know if it's
necessarily been forgotten about it's
one that i kind of feel like doesn't it
like i said even when people are talking
about underrated movies i feel like it's
one that doesn't get brought up much the
same writer director also made a movie
called suburban gothic which came out in
2014 which is also uh really really good
more of like i said more of a dark
comedy i don't remember it being quite
as gory or as bloody or as gross as this
one although it's been a while since
i've seen it i think that one's also on
to be and he made one uh in 2016 called
trash fire which i haven't seen yet but
i've heard like a lot of good things
about it so i've added that to my list
as well as if my list wasn't long enough
now the interesting thing about this one
well there's a lot of interesting things
about this one one there is a [ __ ] ton
of i hesitate to call them cameos
because i kind of feel like i'm going to
say the word cammie like celebrity cameo
usually that just means hey i'm going to
show up for five seconds or whatever
there's a lot of like what you would
call celebrity cameos in this but they
mostly have like two or three scenes so
it's not like they're just popping up
for five seconds going like hey look
it's me you know what i mean it's not
that kind of thing they are actually
like characters
and uh interestingly one of the main
parts in this is played by tracy lords
and tracy lourdes
is kind of playing i guess you could say
she's playing like against type in this
because she's playing like this really
uptight
uh kind of very conservative southern
mother who's trying to keep her like
family together and she's great in this
i mean you wouldn't think because that's
like i said that's not normally the type
of role she plays but i mean this i i
think this is the best thing that i've
seen her in like acting wise she is just
really really good in this now uh
interestingly too i was going to say
about all the cameos listen to this
listen to this you guys is there tracy
lords i don't call that a cameo because
she's like a main character
but
the sort of cameo they're only in two or
three scenes you got uh malcolm mcdowell
playing a math teacher
you got marley matlin who is playing is
she like a guidance counselor or some
kind of camp she's somewhere that like
works at the school or whatever uh ray
wise who plays the principal of the high
school and john [ __ ] waters john
waters is in this as a priest
so
already you can see
so like i said that cast should kind of
give you an idea of the sort of vibe
this movie is like i said this is a very
weird it almost kind of you guys
remember that movie happiness when the
[ __ ] did that come out
todd sollins or however you pronounce
that dude's last name this reminded me
of a movie like that
but
with
really intense gross like body horror so
it's almost kind of like a cronenberg
type of thing going on too but then it's
this kind of like weird [ __ ] up like
dark comedy
family drama type [ __ ] too
uh like i said it's kind of hard to
explain but like i said if you're
squeamish uh particularly about
menstrual stuff you probably will not i
mean
you know this is
this is the kind of movie that has a
scene in it with
you know somebody pulling out a used
tampon and sniffing it and you know
reaching up and like pulling out a
like a baby and like throwing it in an
oven and stuff like that so it's that it
has that kind of like uh imagery so if
that's gonna bother you then you
probably uh we're not are not gonna dig
it now
the best thing about this movie though
uh among many awesome things about this
is that the main character pauline who
is like a high school senior
she's played by anna lynn mccord
now i thought i had seen her before i'm
not super familiar with the work she's
been like on a lot of tv i think she's
probably best known for uh being on
niptuck and she was also on the late
2000s uh 90210 reboot so she's usually
known for playing these kind of really
like vixen type like the beautiful type
women
and
the fact that in this movie
she
goes for it she just uglies herself up
so she is
unrecognizable because like i went later
because after i heard about
you know the parts she usually plays and
i went and looked her up and i'm like
holy crap i wouldn't even like realize
that was the same woman this isn't even
the kind of thing you know how like in
hollywood movies sometimes they'll be
like oh the homely girl and it's like
they'll just pull her hair back into
ponytail and like put glasses on her and
then just like call it a day and they're
just like oh look actually she's really
beautiful i'm like yeah you can still
clearly see that
not so uh in this case i'm not actually
really really even sure
what they did to make her look like that
but i mean a lot of it is in her
physical performance like she's always
kind of like slouching and she's always
like
doing these weird and they kind of put
like zits and cold sores and her hair is
like always really greasy and they put
her in like these really gross like like
baggy like unflattering clothes but just
everything about her
um is
repellent
and yet
you she's still kind of likable so like
i said this is kind of an amazing
uh role for analyn mccord because
i mean who would have thought like
considering like what i'm you know i
looked through her resume and stuff like
that and like i said she usually plays
kind of a glam a glamorous type of
character and so the fact that she had
this in her
and was able to pull off a character
that was this
repulsive
honestly not just physically but she
does like repulsive things as well
uh but she's so off-putting and yet
she's still like really compelling and
she's still like kind of sympathetic in
a way even though she's clearly
very very mentally ill but i kind of
want to get into that a little bit too
because i just her character in this is
like so fascinating to me
so uh so yeah so she plays
a character named pauline who is a high
school senior
now
she basically
she's a terrible student she doesn't
give a [ __ ] about school yet she still
has these kind of delusions of grandeur
where she thinks that she's going to be
a surgeon someday even though she's i
don't know if she's like flunking out
but she's like not
she she's like not even bothering doing
schoolwork and stuff
so she lives in this family uh her mom
like i said phyllis played by tracy
lords is this really really uptight like
very proper you know all
pauline needs like to get her on track
is to like send her to cotillion classes
and stuff like that so it's kind of like
a southern you know kind of a very
southern conservative like religious
type of thing not over the top religious
but
that is that is in there
uh so she plays the you know that's the
mom and then the dad is just kind of
like this whatever he's just like the
spineless dude that whatever his wife
says that's yeah fine whatever i'm just
like not even worried about it and then
pauline also has a younger sister named
grace who has cystic fibrosis
and um
is probably dying you know what i mean
she's she doesn't seem like that but
you know they do kind of imply that that
might be where that's going
so the interesting thing too is that the
family dynamic obviously pauline and her
mother do not get along because
phyllis is a very very proper like
pearls and you know like little little
suit and everything like that and she's
just always very immaculate
and so she sees this slouching
greasy
zit riddle daughter who is just
fascinated by blood and gross [ __ ] and
it's just like constantly disgusting
um so it really like offends her
sensibilities so they're always kind of
like butting heads the interesting thing
about pauline's character which you
don't see a lot in this because i've
seen this movie compared to carrie too
but it's not really the same thing and
it's really not the same thing as may
either because even though this is a
girl
that you know you know like i said is an
outsider is repulsive to most people
is a very off-putting character she
doesn't
you know how like in may and in kerry
like they were very aware of their
outsider status and they um you know
were really upset about it you know they
got picked on and that would upset them
and it's just kind of like so they were
always kind of trying to fit in
pauline has a thing where she doesn't
really seem to care if she fits in or
not and it's almost kind of like she
gets i don't know if i'd say like she
gets off on it but she kind of
she's very um straightforward with her
weirdness and her disgustingness and she
does not really seem all that bothered
that people think that she's gross you
know what i mean
for an example of this is that she has
decided
that she's going to lose her virginity
and she's very matter-of-fact about this
like she has decided that this is what
she's gonna do and this is how she's
gonna go about it
um also because she's super fascinated
by blood
she really wants to uh the first time
she has sex she wants to have sex she's
on her period right
so she chooses like i said very
dispassionately she chooses the the
lucky guy right who's this guy named
adam
who's going out with this kind of like
stereotypical blonde mean girl like a
popular girl at school
and so she essentially just like walks
up to him like when he's out in the you
know sitting on the bleachers or
whatever like talking to his friends and
it's like i've decided that i'm going to
lose my virginity to you and he's just
kind of like okay
like whatever like he doesn't like know
how to react and so she's just like
here's my number call me so she's just
like very she doesn't really seem to
care like i said that other people think
she's gross because you know later
there's like a scene in the locker room
where the mean girls are like picking on
her and saying like how disgusting she
is and it's like oh she looks like a
lesbian and all this other kind of stuff
and she doesn't i mean it could be
because they do show some scenes of her
later where she's by herself and she
seems to be like upset about stuff but
in the moment she really doesn't seem
all that bothered
by you know she she just kind of like
gives it back to them like you know this
is she does so she doesn't get like
all that that's kind of the interesting
thing about her like i said and i think
that that's where a lot of the comedy in
this stems from is that her character is
just so
it's just so repellent and so disgusting
but you can't help but kind of like her
in a way because she's also like kind of
she's clearly very intelligent she's
kind of a smart ass a little bit you
know it's like she's the kind of person
that they're in like biology class or
something and they're talking about
sexually transmitted diseases and she
just like very proudly raises her hand
and said can you get an std from having
sex with a dead person like everyone
just like turns around and looks at her
but she doesn't seem and i don't know if
it's that
it's car it's hard to tell whether the
character whether she comes across is
like she's not aware of how weird she is
because she does really seem to be aware
of how weird and gross she is
but
it's almost kind of like she's daring
people
to
call her out on it or she almost kind of
like wants to inflict it on other people
like she kind of gets off on it um so
it's that kind of thing too like i said
i'm making her sound like this monstrous
character which she is
but
she's still like really interesting and
you still want to watch her and she's
still kind of funny because like the
stuff she does is just so nasty and it's
just like [ __ ] i don't know it's just
like so hilarious
so yeah so uh adam the boy who
you don't think that he's actually gonna
because everybody at school like i said
thinks she's just this she thinks she's
disgusting so but he does actually end
up calling her because you know he's a
teenage boy he's like he's gonna take
sex anywhere he can get it
so
he takes her to a hotel room
and uh they have there's this like
really uncomfortable scene where because
i forgot to mention too that there's not
only this kind of stuff going on
but
they're also showing and actually the
first shot of the film
is pauline's
uh dreams or her fantasy life
now in her fantasies
she is and
this is just goes to show like how
amazing this performance is because the
first time i watched this movie it took
me like an embarrassingly long
embarrassingly long time
to realize that pauline like the
disgusting girl is the same as the woman
that's in these visions that she has
like these sexual fantasies
because in that one i guess annalynne
mccord looks more like she would
normally look like you know when she's
doing another like show or whatever so
they have her like very very super model
and there's all these really kind of
cool i mean visually very very striking
images of just like like i said [ __ ]
up [ __ ] where she
she is like sexually excited by
blood and surgery and dismemberment and
you know disembowelment so she's like
into that kind of [ __ ] and like a little
bit necrophilia too they kind of uh hit
it right at that mostly surgery types of
like cutting people open and things like
that so she's kind of into that so
throughout the film you kind of get a
lot of these really awesome like visual
sequences that are that are really like
they're lit almost like kind of this
super modely type of thing but like this
really harsh light and then it's just
these crazy like tableaus with like all
these supermodel women like with you
know their viscera like hanging out and
there's just blood everywhere so when
she loses her virginity to this atom kid
even though obviously it's just in a
hotel room and it's just kind of this
you know very very workmanlike situation
in her head she's seeing it like this
crazy like because they keep cutting
back and forth to how she's seeing it
it's like there's just all this blood
coming out of the bed and she's like
splashing around and it's just kind of
like so like i said this is a very very
gory
very bloody
cat film so uh so yeah so is so i guess
maybe
that that's like the way that she uh
envisions
the things that are happening
it's interesting because it shows like
how i guess delusional she is because
maybe that's how she sees herself or she
sees everything
so maybe that's why she doesn't get all
upset when like people make fun of her
because that's like her image of herself
in her head and like i said she's
clearly very delusional because she
thinks she's gonna grow up and be this
great surgeon
even though she can't even be bothered
to you know do her math homework or
anything like that and she's kind of
like flunking out of school
so it so there's that kind of thing too
and i think there's kind of an
undercurrent
of you know which kind of becomes more
clear as the movie goes on and like i
said this is kind of where it where it
shades into like a dark comedy and it
has like aspects of tragedy as well
is that pauline's character
even though her and her mother are just
constantly at odds all the time and
she's always she's really like really
mean to her mother and her mother's
really mean to her and it's you know and
there's kind of like a um suggestion too
that you know tracy lord's the mother
that her mother uh was really cruel to
her as well and she so she as the movie
goes on she becomes kind of a more
subtly shaded character too because
you're wondering she's worrying it's
like am i repeating the cycle of abuse
am i doing the same thing to her that
you know my mother did to me and all of
a sudden it's not physical abuse but
it's kind of like emotional abuse where
she's just constantly picking at her and
she's never good enough and all this
other kind of stuff and um but there's a
thing on pauline's part too where
the reason that she wants to be this big
masterful surgeon is one not only
because she loves her sister more than
anything and her sister is dying of
cystic fibrosis so i think there's an
underlying thing that pauline thinks
she's gonna be
the person that's gonna you know
discover something that's gonna save her
sister but also because she wants to
impress her mother she finally wants her
mother's approval so even though it
seems on the surface that she hates her
mother um she's like constantly trying
to get approval from her and i think
that's kind of like the depth of
uh what their relationship is which as i
said it's as the movie goes on becomes a
more and more
a big part of the story so as it goes on
it gets to a point uh pauline ends up
getting expelled from school because
after the one of the mean girls that was
adam's girlfriend
finds out that adam slept with
uh pauline
and was really like grossed out because
like i said she said hey why don't you
go down on me and he does but it's like
and since she had her period and he was
like really grossed out which like i
don't know that just made me laugh but
um
that kind of stuff in movies always
cracks me up i don't know but uh but
yeah so that made me laugh so he was
like disgusted and then the girlfriend
found out about it so so the girlfriend
and her other friend i guess they go and
like spray paint [ __ ] like uh spring
like horror and stuff like that all over
pauline's house like the family house
and then pauline goes into school and
basically like beats up one of the girls
like slams her head into a locker and
like breaks her nose or something like
that so pauline ends up getting expelled
now at this point like i said up until
now
phyllis the mom she's been
you know because it seems to another
thing that's kind of tragic about this
is that pauline as
you know repellent as she is as kind of
like standoffish as she is she's always
very snarky and things like that but
she does seem to be like asking for help
she knows that something is the matter
with her uh but it seems like everyone's
kind of dismissing it or minimizing it
so she does seem like in a lot of ways
she's kind of crying out for help even
though she's being like real sarcastic
about it it's and it's funny because
like the parents
you know she has a conversation with her
mom
and her mom's like you know we're not
made of money and we can't afford to
send you to a psychiatrist so they had
been sending her to this like counselor
at the church who was like priest who's
played by john waters like i said and uh
obviously um
pauline is really not getting anything
out of this and basically just spends
the whole sessions just like denigrating
him because she's not really sure she
believes in god or not and she thinks
he's not licensed and you know so she
does really seem to know that she is
that there's something severely the
matter with her and that she needs help
but
you know she's not really getting the
help that she needs and like i said it's
not really entirely her family's fault
because they don't
seem to realize how
drastic and how uh you know how awful
her mental illness is and how serious it
is um but finally at some point after
she gets expelled from school
um the mom and dad they finally come to
this decision they're like look we're
gonna suck it up and we're gonna get you
like to a real psychiatrist will that
make you feel better because it's like
you know we really want to do something
for you
however before that happens there's kind
of like a thing where
pauline overhears her mother just like
flipping out and just being like i can't
she's like i keep trying and trying with
her and it's you know and i just i can't
she says something like i just can't
love her or it's so hard to love her and
pauline like overhears this and gets
like really upset and like starts crying
and everything so she does feel that her
mother does not accept her the way she
is or does not really love her and this
maybe is like stemming you know
obviously feeding into her problem and
then that kind of leads to
the very terrible conclusion
uh of the movie which i don't
necessarily think i want to spoil
because i think
although if you've seen the movie you
can pretty much guess where it's going
because it's kind of like leading up to
that it's not so much like ooh twist or
anything like that because it is just
kind of like the whole thing is kind of
like watching her
you know get kind of crazier and crazier
and you know that it's kind of leading
to this inevitable conclusion because it
keeps getting brought up so you're
almost kind of like waiting for the next
shoe to drop it's like oh man this is
gonna be bad when this happens uh
because everything's kind of leading to
that
but i don't think i'm necessarily gonna
spoil it because
like i said even though this movie came
out in 2012 i feel like
i just don't feel like a lot of people
talk about it and that's like a shame as
i said i hadn't even heard of it until i
came across it on a list and i was like
oh that sounds kind of good and then
like i saw all the you know all the
cameos all the people that were in it
i'm like holy [ __ ] how did i miss this
one uh so yeah so i definitely went and
watched it and it was like i was not
disappointed it's just really really
it's a really really good movie like i
said it has a lot of horror elements
it's very gory it's very gross
um you know like i said very a lot of
menstrual stuff a lot of like abortion
stuff a lot of you know stuff like that
so like kind of squeaky
sort of stuff a lot of surgery uh you
know evisceration people taking
you know uh organs out and stuff like
that so there's all that kind of stuff
um and it has like a really
like but done in a really like artistic
sort of way like i said so it's almost
kind of like cronenberg it's almost like
brandon cronenberg now that i want to
because it's kind of reminded me of like
some of brandon cronenberg stuff too but
uh where it's just kind of like this
it's like beautiful but like grotesque
you know what i mean but then like the
rest of it is almost kind of like
a suburban
black comedy
but with like tragedy kind of
swirled around underneath it that gets
like more and more tragic at the end but
yeah it's just this is really really
worth watching if anything that i said
sounds like uh something that would be
your cup of tea then i would definitely
recommend this one i feel like it's
under seen it doesn't get talked about
enough and it's really really good like
i said it's on
if you have amazon prime at least as of
this recording it's on there for free
like i said there's on there for to rent
for a couple dollars too but i'm pretty
sure it's the same so don't worry about
it so you can watch it for free or if
you don't have amazon prime you can
watch it for free on to be i would also
recommend um his other movie this
director's other movie suburban gothic
which came out in 2014. like i said i
kind of feel like i don't remember that
one being as gory or as like grotesque
or like arty as this one
but it was still like really fun i
really it's like kind of a black comedy
as well a horror comedy um and like i
said he made another one called trash
fire which i haven't seen yet but i have
actually heard a lot of good stuff about
that so i'm gonna put that on my list as
well and i'll probably eventually end up
reviewing it i'll probably do suburban
gothic too now that i'm thinking about
it
because i really wouldn't mind watching
that one again but yeah so it's called
excision and uh go watch it and if
you've seen it let me know what you
thought about it in the comments and i
will see you guys on the next one
bye